your toes are still smoking and the rest
of you - Jessie was one of the most
promising disney channel sitcoms of its
time only to be canceled after four
seasons so what went wrong stay until
the end to find the biggest secret
Disney tried to hide from Jessie fans
[Music]
they pulled an episode did you know that
there's a Jessie episode you'll never be
able to see anywhere Disney was forced
to pull it after many complaints from
the general audience the public signed a
petition to remove the episode that
shamed children with gluten allergies
and Disney was forced to take action in
the episode a child called Stuart is
introduced as being sensitive to gluten
and the show decided to portray him as
annoying and high-maintenance is
creating a dangerous draft on the guest
chair he ends up getting pancakes thrown
in his face and while the studio
audience did laugh parents definitely
didn't well we know Disney loves to
highlight certain lifestyles and make a
joke out of the situation they did take
it a little bit too far with the
storyline after more than 2,000 people
had signed the petition Disney was
forced to take action
they later released a statement saying
they deeply apologize that the episode
made some viewers upset and that they
will reevaluate its references to gluten
restrictions of course there were mixed
opinions on the episode and while some
didn't think that it was a big deal it
was a sensitive topic for parents whose
kids already frequently get mocked for
their food allergies have you seen its
controversial episode arrested just a
year after the show enough about the
show let's dive into some serious
secrets from our favorite Jesse's stars
we've all seen several Disney stars
spiral out of control through the years
from Lindsay Lohan's and her troubles
with the law Demi Lovato and her battle
with her mental illness
it looks like being a child actor comes
with the price Debby Bryan also had her
share of controversial mishap but one of
the most notable ones was her arrest
that happened just a year after the
show's final air date debbie describes
herself as a nerd but this nerd totally
filled her sobriety test after she
crashed her car in
- a Mercedes she was arrested and put on
a $100,000 bail which is a lot of money
debbie has since then apologized for her
reckless decisions and said she does
realize that she's in fact a role model
to many and although this incident
happened after Jessi was already over it
certainly makes parents raise even more
eyebrows and wonder if their Disney star
is actually a good role model for their
children since then Debbie decided to
shake off her Disney label and started
focusing on acting opportunities outside
of the Disney Channel Debbie Ryan's dark
friendships
Debbie's friendships also took a dark
turn after she shared a very serious
insight into her love life in 2015 when
Debbie was just 21 and Jesse just
wrapped its final episode
Debbie opened up in a people interview
and talked about her long abusive
relationship she never revealed the name
but Debbie talks about how her
friendship turned into a very
emotionally and physically abusive
relationship that was hard to get out of
she spoke how it went on for a couple of
years and it's safe to say it's also
occurred while she was still filming
Jesse so while she looked happy and
bubbly on the show Debbie said it took a
while to realize that what was happening
to her wasn't in fact healthy she
described her experience as frightening
and mentioned this person would call her
up to 40 times per day when she wouldn't
be around him
they were lifelong friends but things
came to an end when her friend
threatened to end his life if she
wouldn't spend time with him Debbie also
shared the backlash she received for
talking about her relationship her
ex-boyfriend reached out to her and
criticized her for daring to speak up
about the issue because he was afraid
the public would think it was him on the
other hand her now former friend also
reached out to her to apologize why did
it end earlier the team behind Jesse
planned to make the show one of the
longest-running Disney Channel shows but
the crown still belongs to Wizards of
Waverly Place and it's 106 episodes so
why did Jesse end after 98 episodes do
you have any idea how annoying kids can
be it's still not clear why the show got
cancelled in the first place and when a
fan directly tweeted at Debbie asking
her that same question she responded
that the show ran its course
and hit 100 episodes you have to admit
that the show was pretty impressive even
though it didn't reach their end goal
and got canceled it seems like everyone
was just ready to move on to new
adventures debby ryan and skye jackson
feud and here it is one of the biggest
controversies of the jesse show that
shed light on the acting world and how
not everything is as good as it seems
debby ryan is actually really good
friends with her ex co-stars it's
unclear where she stands with Skye
Jackson who plays Zuri Ross on the show
Suri is also one of the main characters
and the Jessi spin-off bunked but did
you know that she and Debbie didn't
actually get along at the beginning of
Jessi the two were really close and
showed off cute photos on social media
but in 2014 Skye unfollowed Debbie on
Twitter fans started to wonder what's
happening between the two and it looks
like they haven't exactly mended their
friendship this guy seemed to have a
secret Twitter account that claimed
Debbie actually bullied her on the show
but after the rumor had broken out Skye
confirmed Debbie was rude to her on her
main Twitter account in an awkward
interview Skye was also asked about
Debbie and answered that they just went
their separate ways and to do their own
thing Debbie of course fire back at
Skye's bullying claims in a long tumblr
post Debbie addressed the issue and said
she wishes every child actor would have
emotional security and complete content
Skye posted a Jessi throwback shortly
after and blurred out Debbie's face on
the picture could this be the main
reason why Jessie got canceled so early
don't forget to click that button and
subscribe to our Channel see you next
time